okay hey everyone it's Michael BOS and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for Monday June 26 2017 durable
orders were mostly negative this morning
um including both orders and shipments
for capital goods and you know this kind
of spells a little bit trouble for
second quarter GDP when that number
comes
out you know I I read a headline that
said well Market's a little changed but
actually you know there was um you know
quite a bit of movement in the uh S&P
for the day I mean you know even though
you see uh Market were quiet and little
changed you know if you were to look on
just on the chart you had quite a big
range actually in the S&P um 18 points
you got this big wick here but if you
just look at the body it's kind of a
small body you know a little bit up so
it looks like oh it's only up uh a small
small amount little change but actually
you did get some decent price movement
during the day so you know another
interesting thing was uh potential flash
crash in the gold uh I also heard fat
finger um caused it but um you know
before I get into that let me just go
through a brief disclaimer I don't
everyone get all excited and think
Futures Trading is the way to go way to
your riches yes you can make money
trading but you know not everyone will
so this presentation is for educational
and informational purposes only should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
training contains substantial risk and
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trade trading and only those
with sufficient risk Capital should
consider trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
tools I use in this presentation are the
order flows trainer and the Delta
scalper so um you know first I'll just
talk about the gold um you know it's
quite interesting there's an interesting
article on Zero Hedge about it um it
sort of alluded to a flat fat finger
what the fat finger is refers to is a
trading error you know when someone you
when a Trader on a dealing desk is
keying in in order you know instead of
200 they enter 2,000 um that's a fat
finger and you know those mistakes do
happen uh I've I've had them myself
although not to the tune like this or
you know sometimes is I supposed to
enter um 20 Lots I enter 200 usually I
catch it you know the problem the
problem that really arises with fat
fingers is when people enter
price as the quantity
and the quantity as price you know vice
versa that's uh usually where things get
wiped out you know you could research on
the Japanese Market it happens every few
years a big big problem you know where
um somebody was supposed to you know a
few years ago someone suppos enter like
uh one lot and they entered 19,000 Lots
because the stock was trading at 19,000
and and they they put 19,000 as a
quantity in a price of one so they sold
$199,000 down to a price of one now you
know for retail Traders it's generally
not going to happen because you're um
there's a gooey that sits on your
trading system
so you can't trade outside of basically
what you have on deposit with your
broker yeah I they they do restrict you
even if you know you got a ton of money
you usually have a quantity limit you
know every new account goes through the
onboarding process and there's a form
that you have that the the bank will
fill out or or the broker will fill out
which is basically your your position
limits and your trade size limits so you
know most most firms you know for retail
Traders you can't trade more than 25
Lots unless you get special approval so
maybe you could trade 50 so you're not
going to have a fat finger but when
you're trading at a bank the last thing
a bank Trader wants to have
is uh a basically a size um a position
not a position limit but an order size
limit all right you know there are guys
I I know guys at JP Morgan sell you know
they'll hit the bid in the Euro dollars
not the euro currency the Euro dollars
which is you know sometimes 3 4,000 Lots
aside they'll see a bid you know 87 bid
for 3,500 boom they'll sell all 3,500
just like that no problem and you know
if they're trying to enter and they get
a popup that says oh um you know you're
exceeding your max order size limit the
order won't go through and they'll get
really pissed off and they'll raise hell
because you know these guys are big
swinging dicks for the bank oh I make
the bank $20 million a year trading I
don't want to be [__] around with you
know having to enter a thousand lot a
thousand lot a thousand lot like that um
you know those guys will they'll make
noise and they'll get these things
removed they'll get these they not banks
are not supposed to do that right
they're not supposed to remove it but
you know what you yell at some little
guy that that sits there um you I'll say
in a cubical I mean he's he's got a Kush
Kush office you know next to some um
pretty girls in accounting and you know
here he is getting yelled at by some guy
he said [__] it I don't need this okay
boom removed you know so these things
they get removed and you know that's how
these these things happen um you know
whether or not this one um is a fat
finger I don't know you know I mean it's
18,000 lots and traded in a minute you
know normally it doesn't trade that size
at that time of day um 4:00 a.m. eastern
time 3:00 a.m. Chicago time Europe is
just you know early morning it's Monday
morning gold though only sold off 18
bucks you know it's only 1 and a half%
so it's not like it was down 5% 6% so
you know it did get absorbed to a
certain extent I mean it's $2
billion notional um obviously it's going
to drag down other markets but again you
know that amount at that time is is is
quite a lot actually so don't think
um I don't know don't don't there's a
lot of conspiracy theories
floating around I did ask some of my
friends uh brokerage friends if that was
them they said no but again you know can
it be a central bank yeah it can now
granted you know there's a holiday in
most of Asia right and it's 3:00 a.m.
Chicago time so Asia is pretty much
closed um Europe is just opening now
granted there's some um Banks having
some problems in Italy although um you I
think I was reading somewhere the size
of the uh position is like 300
tons which you know central banks do
come out and
sell you know sell 300 tons I me they
used to you know um but you know that
was like a big thing so I don't know you
know I don't know what to make of this I
don't know necessarily know if it's a
it's a fat finger or someone just
dumping it just honestly it doesn't make
sense to be dumping it at that time if
someone really wants to dump a position
like that they would just wait till you
know the time when it's most liquid um
you know so you know that's why know
timing of it you know sort of lends
itself to being a fat finger but again
you know you can sell 18,000 lots and
only move the market 1% um you know that
that's not all that bad I I do like the
comments though on some of these things
um you know
here's uh there's a good comment in here
[Music]
somewhere I can't find it
now it's probably gone um but um you
know I mean I like the comments cuz
they're T you know the sarcastic ones
you know I've got sort of a a a Gallows
humor um but anyway you know that that
said yeah that was interesting this
morning um the the other thing is yeah
usually when you get a fat finger this
is the chart um I'm not going to pull up
a chart but this is you know the chart
that's in this article you can see how
it's sold off from here to here and
retrace back it didn't retrace all the
way back um you don't necessarily have
to you know in the old days when you see
fat fingers what you would get Is Not
only would you get the fat finger then
you'd get follow through you know cuz
you know stops are getting triggered and
then the market um just keeps going
lower and then snaps back literally
right around to where it was it it
pulled back
to you know still a little bit I still
about uh you know half a percent lower
so um you know if it's truly truly a fat
finger in my opinion you'd see the sell
off and you'd really rally back to where
you were almost EX ly before but you
know what there's probably still some
selling pressure in here you know people
got a lot of stuff getting triggered
here um and on the way down you know you
got stops right and generally when
people are working stops
electronically well everything's
electronically you got to put a limit
you're not going to just put a stop okay
now I know
people big Traders they don't want to
miss the move so they'll just put a stop
with a very wide limit you know1 $10 or
something in in in Gold you think hey
you know $10 I'm pretty safe so you know
you're training 55 you know maybe they
put you know a $10 limit down here at 55
that's why you see it come back up here
to 55 so what you had is you had a lot
of stops getting triggered on the way
down when you know the selling came in
and they didn't get anything now but now
they're working stops or sorry limit
here because their stop is you know at
1255 or something you know with a $10 um
limit so when it gets down to 1245
if they don't get anything it's working
as a limit in the order book right
that's how you see it sort of come back
up around this level and just sort of
hang there that's why I think you know
we stayed under it for a while again I I
didn't I don't have a gold chart I I
should pull up a gold chart U maybe
later but it was just interesting
interesting uh things going around in
the market this morning um that
said again you know go back to the S&P
then today
um even though you know I said you know
early on I saw headlin saying uh the Dow
is narrow trading range and we ended up
just posting a small gain but when you
know when when you look at the uh the
chart it's it's just really more you
know there was some decent movements
there
was some very good movements um this is
okay well be on just really quick this
is the Delta sorry this is the mini da
the ym mar 100 range chart and yeah
there's some terrific uh terrific moves
here this is the transition I like
running the transition on 100 tick chart
you know Cash open we're training around
21405 we rally up to 450 you got a
little bit of a sell here then you get
this nice brilliant sell here at around
the uh 430 area right there and you know
you sell off down to basically down to
330 um you know you did sort of Hold
Steady around this 350 360 area um you
know you go lower a little bit a sell
here not much there um back up 385
another sell you do rally back up here a
little back and forth another sell
around the 390
area you know then you're just sort of
going sideways the rest of the day
sideways to lower so you know there was
some decent movements there you know
that's the that's the transition um
indicator but uh you know looking on a
on a 10 range e mini chart um not not
I'll say not a whole lot in the in the
order flow I mean in the sense of you
know ratios with divergences to not not
a whole lot actually in a lot of the
markets that I'm following but you know
Delta scalper is giving you you know a
buy Here a sell here um this is a nice
swing High you can't get past it um but
again you know it's you know after that
initial move up and sell off you know we
literally after about 11:00 you just
went
sideways but again you know Delta scaler
has given a couple signals there
interest rates um you know bonds Bond's
very quiet this morning we kept bumping
up against this High here at uh at 08 um
couldn't get past it boom boom boom all
these divergences here you got a ratio
of Divergence here you got the Delta
scalper Delta scalper cell at the same
level a few times um finally late in the
day you came off but again you know you
get it once twice three times four times
five times before finally making that
move lower again you know I'm not going
to say oh you had Delta scul you had I
mean Delta scul or sell here yeah you
had one here did the market
react I mean it's I can say yeah look at
it you could have sold it here and cover
it down here no um to me this is the
market didn't move it's just going
sideways here at least you got you know
a rational in Divergence but you know
you came right back up to that high and
then you sold off but again you know
this was a very slow moving day you know
this is at 10 it doesn't make the move
till 12 I don't think I'd have that
patience um five
years find my fiveyear chart here you
are um kind of similar you know we
rallied up um from this low uh 4:30 in
the morning hit the high came within a
tick of it here it's a Divergence not a
ratio it's close to you know I mean if I
was using 75 it'd be a ratio but I
ed7 um so not not technically a ratio
got back up within one tick got back up
within one tick got back up within one
tick um you know Delta scalper here
price rejector there but again you know
this you know today would have been one
of those days where you're just where
you are just um sort of spinning your
wheels you know thinking [__] man
today's you know trading sucks CU there
there there's not a whole lot of uh
great trading opportunities the uh Euro
currency just really quick I'll just
show you on on a on a bar chart um I'll
get into the orderflow chart in a second
here um didn't get a signal here didn't
work out came right back up then you got
a nice signal here around the 11260 area
um sold down till you get the next buy
here around the 112 um 40 area but by
this time it's already you know almost
uh 12:00 but on the uh on
the on the Oro chart you know this is
how it looked this morning not um you
know this is this is that cell that
didn't work out again not not much uh in
terms of ratios you have a Divergence
there um you know nothing you know I
like ratios with divergences not just
divergences by
themselves you know here's that Delta
scalper given a cell again we rally
right up near the high start coming off
Delta scalper given the cell
and you get the Delta scalper by there
not a whole lot uh really other than the
Delta scalper I mean that's why you know
I create tools like the Delta scalper
cuz honestly on boring days it's it's
tough it's difficult to trade because
you're bored out of your [__] mind um
you know and then last thing you want to
be doing is you know drop your focus you
know it's easy to open up Facebook and
start chatting with people but um you
know then you're going to end up missing
trades so Japanese Yen here you know
7:30 at the numbers then you got you
know Delta scalper giv a buy here it's a
kind of short lived up here at the next
bar or two starts coming back
down you get
this stacked imbalance sort of in the
middle of this area you just been
trading around again um yeah does this
one work yeah this one works
out um Delta scalper given a buy here
after you hit the swing low um next bar
up next bar up and then you just sort of
go sideways in here again you know it's
encouraging over the next two bars but
then you get run into Red Bar Red Bar
point of control right at the top here
price rejector there you know so it's
telling you it's not going to be very
effective anymore after that again you
know look for signs once you're in a
trade that you know in the order flow
you're seeing some bearish signs up in
here over these these two red bars that
the Market's not moving again if if
you're still in this trade you know by
the time it's out here you you shouldn't
be you know it's more negative than
positive at this point in this last bar
here here anyway um Del Scupper gives a
buy but it's on a red candle so I'm not
interested in taking that as as a
trade sell off into new lows boom some
stops start going off down in here late
in the day boom boom boom you get down
here Divergence no ratio it's close it's
741 would I be interested I mean I don't
know I know the market just got hammered
right here get got pounded 1326 is this
bar this bar this bar this bar this bar
this bar I'm probably not you know to me
this is just a quick bounce you come
back a little bit later get another
Divergence another Divergence then you
close for the day so again not much
there other than the uh than the Delta
scalper
the soybeans also I'm getting not much
you know very quiet day all around I
mean even though you you did have some
decent movements but you know there
wasn't much clues in the orderflow today
because to me you know when you don't
get stuff in the order flow it's just
the market doing what it's supposed to
do it's facilitating the trade simple as
that I mean that's why the markets exist
they don't exist so people can um you
know scalp them or day trade or anything
like that no they exist the people that
transfer risks the transfer their risk
and the farmer can transfer his risk to
someone else you know locking his price
and you know things like that so anyway
uh 7 sorry 8:30 you know is the
reopen we're up here near our highs boom
boom boom we come down here you got a
few things you got Delta scalper giving
a buy yeah okay doesn't do anything just
goes sideways another buy here but on a
red candle Point control right on the
bottom of this bar you got a nice
bullish ratio does it rally yeah rallies
over the next bar or two you do have the
Delta scalper given a buy here but we
just come down make a new low by one
tick only um and then we start rallying
back all the way up to new highs so
again you know this was this was kind of
difficult I I I I hate it when it comes
down makes a new low by a tick and then
makes that rally I hate those cheap
ticks um those you know ticks lower by a
tick you get up here you got a ratio of
two but you got single print you've got
you know Divergence but again you know I
I really wouldn't be looking to get
short at that time even though it's it's
you know almost it's about 99cent range
just kind of small actually in the beans
um you know then later we we start
coming off from this high but you know
here Delta Scupper by but it's the
Market's closing in about a minute you
know then it
closed um
what
else you know for what it's worth meal
but it's right on the reopen you know
you had a ratio and well let's say ratio
it's a zero print and a Divergence and
then you came off here this was a nice
little buy here um again you know meals
is something I've been uh I used to
trade a lot actually um after I left JP
Morgan that's what I traded for about 6
months was was meal um you meal is a
decent contract it's $10 a
tick and some days you get $10 moves so
you know that's $1,000 so you know if
you just make uh one handle two handles
that's already 100 200 bucks on one lot
so if you're trading you know three lots
that's uh well five could be you know
500 bucks which is decent um it's a nice
contract and you sometimes it's a bit
Jagged but sometimes it's quite smooth
like here you hit this low small Deltas
is coming into this low eight it's um it
is a uh Rao it's a Divergence no ratio
next bar Delta scalper kicks in boom you
get a nice
rally up here to the high you got some
trap Traders up here on the high that's
what this red arrow is and you know you
sell back off you know today's it's
uh usually in in summer times you know I
say Activity but interest in this
contract really picks up it was a slow
day today because I said you know it's
it's a Muslim
holiday I believe in in Asia I'm in the
Philippines but Philippines is not Asian
I do know palm oil is closed Monday and
Tuesday because of I think it's har Ria
and I know I was watching TV here and
you got some you know the TV stations
out here in in Singapore and Malaysia
when it's a Malaysian when it's a
religious holiday they'll say this har
Ria special programming and so I sort of
I heard that
um crude oil let look at crude real
quick crude again you not a whole lot um
as far as ratios and divergences this is
starting at 7 this morning yeah you hit
your low here this red line is the low
no ra no Divergence no ratios here you
got the Delta scoper kicking in over the
next couple bars you know it does it
does trade a little bit higher but it's
not really going anywhere um on you and
then it sort of comes back down we're
start hanging around that yellow orange
opening Price Line um come down new lows
another Divergence but no ratio no ratio
on the next bar you just hang around
here still hanging around that open boom
comes start hitting down into the new
lows some selling imbalances Boom Boom
Boom 1 2 3 4 5 six either These Bars you
know all negative Deltas I don't have
the Delta surge on here but this is the
Delta surge kick would have kicked off
in here I could just uh I don't need it
because I could read it but I do put on
some of my charts cuz whatever the
template has it on there
um come down in here at the low still um
negative Delta start rallying you got
positive Delta but again nothing in that
orderflow really to get too excited
about I thought this was interesting you
know you're just sort of hanging around
here you're sort of getting some
smallish Deltas 90 200 200 although you
got this buying imbalance you I like
buying and balances off lows
honestly um it does occur right at the
top of the bar you know people ask me
does it matter where buying and balance
appears you know if it appears in the
top of a bar in the middle of a bar the
bottom of the bar generally no um it
doesn't have any relevance I haven't
found it at least however when it
appears on a top of a bar especially in
a range
bar because you know the bar is going to
close and form a new bar when you get
outside the range right and sometimes
what you run into with range bars is
when they occur right on the top of a
green bar or right on the bottom of a
red bar is the Market's moving there's
just not enough volume in there you know
up here people want to buy it but in
this bar at this time there's just not
necessarily enough volume and then you
close and you're left with this open
basic I'll say open but you're left with
this imbalance CU you don't have a
chance to come back in and in this bar
it says you know people wanted to buy it
up an extra tick but there's just no
volume there for them to buy so it came
back
down in the next bar um then you get
this stacked imbalance here you know
which I find bearish come down here some
very strong volume here uh 1199 you know
support get through it rally back up
Delta scoper giving a buy here and
finally you got some decent movement off
the lows but again you know at this time
in in here it's not giving you any big
signs you got small Deltas for 611 98
you're going sideways in here okay but I
do know there is some support there was
some decent volume down here um you know
at this level at 68 I think it was 69 um
you you about 2 and a half thousand Lots
traded there
almost so I do know there was some
there's some support down there was some
and we got through it but rallied back
up even over the next couple prices you
know here's about 22,000 here's another
1,500 here's another th000 another,
another 1400 so you know it's quite
decent down there and then you know you
just hit this area Market's trying to
decide which way we going point of
controls in these bars all lining up
again you know watch when you come out
of an area like this um you know watch
what point of controls are doing if it's
they're going higher or they're going
lower in this case they're going
higher watch Delta Delta's picking up 98
163 I I say it's picking up at 98 but
you know you sort of got these you know
in these four bars 46198 it's kind of
small then 163 yeah okay I'm not
convinced yet but boom 800 [__] Buy's
coming in you know you know when you see
800 like that [__] you know your your
ear should prick up and think what the
[__] about to happen next bar strong
700 next bar strong
600 okay then you get Negative you got
some selling okay that's fine I'm not
thinking this move is over because you
got to borrow with negative Delta but
you know at the same time you could read
this negative Delta well okay you why do
I got negative Delta I got some very
supportive buying in here 1 12200 1,200
so I know people are selling into these
bids and there's strong biders there so
instead of reading this as a negative
I'm reading this as a positive for the
market so you start coming out of this
area right with with the small Deltas
you're looking at it yeah really you're
sitting here now this is the time where
you got your phone out and you're you're
scrolling through Facebook you know 4611
98 when 163 okay oh [__]
800 let me pay attention boom 700 buying
is coming in okay 600 you know at this
point if you're not convinced buying is
coming in you're really not applying
yourself you know what you know with
order
flow and you know so even if you get in
here late at um you know 43 bucks um you
there's still capacity this Market keeps
going higher gets all the way up to
about 4350 before it sort of Staples out
again um goes sideways and then starts
um you know getting ready to I say close
for the day but you know you're really
just jumping around this was the move
right this was the move here and the
signs were here you're coming out of
this area of oops it's back
here you got this area with small Deltas
you got this area where people are
trading back and forth sort of I don't
say absorption but or consolidation but
you know that's where moves come out of
they come out of areas of absorption
they come out of areas of congestion
right that's when that's where moves
come out of so you know it's easy to get
bored and sit here ah we're not doing
anything you know point of controls are
all lined up but watch watch what
happens when you come out that's where
the money is going to be
made and you know it was there it was
there for you to pick up off the
ground um you know anyway so later in
the day you know after 1:00 you know
Delta scalper gives a buy here yeah it's
already 1 1:15 here it's 3:00 you
honestly I I'm not a big fan of of
trading crude going into the afternoon
the best time The Sweet Spot To Me is
from um you know basically 5:00 a.m.
until about 1:00
p.m. I know people that like to look at
rig numbers and all that stuff which
come out later but I'm not that hardcore
on on crude so anyway um yeah I hope
this uh this presentation was useful and
maybe you picked up something out of it
maybe not I don't know but to learn more
about trading software in this I use in
this presentation which is my orderflows
Trader software visit orderflow doc
orderflows with an.com um learn more
about deltas scalper go to Deltas
scaler.com so thanks everyone and uh
I'll catch you tomorrow bye-bye